كيف العقيد يوري هنا المتحدث باسم القوات
الجويه
الاوكرانيه اهلا وسهلا بك نريد ان تؤكد
لنا هذه الانباء ان طائرات مسيره اوكرانيه
قامت بهجمات على الدعم السريع في الخرطوم
انتم حصلتم على المعلومه من الممثلين
الاوكرانيين الرسميين انا اتحدث باسم
القوات الجويه ولا استطيع ان اعلق على هذه
المعلومات لانها ليست متاحه لدي بعد عن
هذه الهجمات لذلك هذا السؤال ليس لي عما
يحدث لدينا ما نقوم به في اوكرانيا وعلى
اراضينا لدينا من نحاربهم لذلك قد يكون من
الضروري ان نبحث في هذه المسائل مع
الاشخاص الذين هم لديهم ارتباط مباشر يعني
حسب معلوماتك انت وانت متحدث باسم القوات
الجويه
والطائرات المسيره سلاح الجو المسير جزء
من القوات الجويه هل المسيرات الاوكرانيه
تمارس اي دور في مناطق اخرى من العالم
سواء السودان او غير السودان
في العموم
انا المسيرات ليست جزء من القوات الجويه
ان القوات الجويه هي المقاتلات وانظمه
الدفاع الجويه اما المسيرات تستخدم الان
من قبل جامعه تشكيلات العسكريه سواء كانت
الاستخبارات او القوات الارضيه
لدينا القليل من المسيرات مثل البيرقطار
ولريكا
ومختلف المسيرات الاخرى تستخدم من كل
التشكيلات العسكريه وليس داخل القوات
الجويه يعني ليس لديكم مسيرات في القوات
الجويه
لدينا البيرقطار والتي هي في صفوف
قوه الجويه
وايضا لدينا مختلف الطائرات الهجوميه
ولدينا بعض الدرونات وهي تستخدم من جميع
القوات في الجبهات ما هي يعني كيفيه تعامل
القوات الجويه الاوكرانيه مع مجموعه فاجنر
في مناطق اخرى خارج اوكرانيا هل تعتبرونها
تهديدا وتطاردونها ايضا خارج اوكرانيا
لدى القوات الجويه مهمات محدده
نعم ليست المخابرات الاوكرانيه هي الوحيده
التي تراقب قوه فاغنر بل الكثير من
المخابرات في العالم ونعلم جيدا ما الذي
تقوم به
هي مجموعات من العصابات الارهابيه التي
تستخدمها روسيا تحت اداره بوتين ولقد
اعترف بوتين بهذا اثناء الاحداث التي قام
بها بريجوجن وقال بوتين انه هو من كان
يمول فاجنر لتقوم بمهام تصب في مصلحه
روسيا في افريقيا ومختلف المناطق
وكانت هذه الدول تدعو بعض الدول تدعو
فاجنر حتى تستخدمها وفي التاثيرات الخاصه
بها لذلك هذه
المنظمه تراقبها كل الدول وكل دوله
استخدم وسائلها في مراقبه هذه الحركه في
اوكرانيا اذكر ان هذه المنظمه الارهابيه
حاربت في
محور دانيسك وبغموت وهناك عشرات الافراد
من فارنار قتلت من قبل قواتنا
النظاميه وهناك الكثير من الدلائل التي
صورها بنفسه لذلك علينا ان نقول ان
اوكرانيا دمرت الكثيرين وقامت بكل شيء حتى
تدمر تشكيلات فاقدر
ومستاجرها شكرا جزيلا لكم
المتحدث باسم القوات الجويه الاوكرانيه